y ahora vuelve el espacio dedicado a
economía en las noches de france 24 y
les damos la bienvenida y para eso está
conmigo jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
de nuevo a este momento y comencemos
hablando de la presidenta del banco
central europeo porque se refirió al
aumento de los tipos de interés así es y
bueno me declara según ella este
cualquier tipo de aumento que se ve en
ese continente sería de forma gradual
aunque sí sería significativo porque en
más de una década que no se da la
funcionaria aseguró que esa decisión
seguirá dependiendo de los datos y que
los funcionarios deben ser flexibles a
este tipo de cambios christine lagarde
cambio a un tono más agresivo luego de
la reunión del consejo de gobierno del
banco central europeo esto luego de que
la inflación se disparara el 5,1 por
ciento interanual el mes pasado la cifra
es más del doble del objetivo que tenía
previsto el banco central del 2% el
aumento se debe al alto costo de los
precios de la energía que enfrenta en la
mayoría de los países europeos y en un
momento de tensión geopolítica en europa
del ex pte los rendimientos de la deuda
pública de la zona euro subieron esto
porque muchos inversores
a la subida de los tipos de interés a
partir de marzo y sigamos en europa
porque el público de este continente que
tiene instagram y facebook podría
quedarse sin estas aplicaciones porque
jorge hacía más claro bueno esto luego
de que meta que es la empresa matriz de
facebook amenazara con la posibilidad de
cerrar sus servicios en los países de la
unión europea el motivo una sentencia
judicial que le impide transferir datos
de los usuarios europeos a su sede en
eeuu en su informe a la comisión de
bolsa me está seguro que este fallo del
tribunal de justicia de la unión europea
emitido el 16 de julio del 2020 podría
tener consecuencias para su capacidad de
proveer los servicios las nuevas
restricciones de privacidad del bloque
europeo supone limitaciones para la red
social de personalizar los anuncios que
es básicamente el principal ingreso de
la empresa la decisión de la corte
obliga a la comisión europea a realizar
una revisión de la normativa para eeuu
que sede de varias multinacionales
tecnológicas entre ellas meta en eeuu la
noticia es la fusión de dos aerolíneas
de bajo costo así que se trata de las
compañías
group holdings y spirit airlines que
pretenden crear la quinta mayor
aerolínea de eeuu la unión representa
unos 2.900 millones de dólares que
probablemente reforzará la competencia
contra las compañías tradicionales tras
el anuncio las acciones de spirit
subieron hasta un 18% aunque varios
analistas dudan de la aprobación de
parte de las autoridades de ese país
frontier y spirit presentan su fusión
como un contrapeso a american delta
united y softwares que juntas controlan
cerca del 80% del mercado aéreo
estadounidense la función se anuncia en
un momento volátil en el contexto de la
pandemia de kobe 19 donde este sector ha
sido uno los grandes perdedores las
pérdidas en el cuarto trimestre para las
compañías fueron 87 2 millones de
dólares para spirit y 53 millones para
afrontar en eeuu hay otra noticia y es
que continúa el enfrentamiento comercial
de este país con china así es bueno el
nuevo capítulo incluye restricciones o
el ingreso a la lista roja de 33
empresas chinas y cuya legitimidad no
puede ser por gobierno de eeuu así lo
dijo el departamento de comercio de eeuu
que informó que estaba agregando más
compañías a la conocida lista no
verificada una lista de empresas de todo
el mundo que están sujetas a controles
más estrictos de las exportaciones
porque los funcionarios americanos no
pueden verificar a totalidad su estatus
entre ellas ahora están 33 empresas de
la república china el anuncio se da en
el contexto de los juegos olímpicos de
invierno en beijing al que eeuu lanzó un
boicot diplomático y la semana pasada el
director del fbi aseguró que cada 12
horas investigan o abren investigaciones
relacionadas con operaciones de
inteligencia china y que ninguna otra
nación del mundo representa un riesgo
tan amplio para la seguridad económica
de eeuu como es china jorge y cuáles son
los indicadores del día arrancamos marie
claire con wall street que cerró con
pérdidas generalizadas y sin apenas
variaciones en el town zone luego de una
sesión que se tornó volátil en europa la
bolsa de parís cerró con ganancia su
principal índice subió un 0,83 por
ciento y la bolsa de buenos aires en
américa cerró este lunes con una subida
del 1,42 por ciento y la cifra del día 7
millones de dólares eso en promedio un
anuncio de 30 segundos en el superbowl
de los más de 70 anuncios 30 eran nuevos
anunciantes increíble jorge bueno
gracias por esta información y gracias a
ustedes por estar conectados con
france24
[Música]